foreign
[Music]
tense podcast please take a second and
hit subscribe we have a guest who really
really lives up to the name of the
pretty intense podcast and his name is
Randall Carlson he has a podcast called
cosmographia he is also a Geo
mythologist he has been studying the
planetary evolution of the continent's
water impacts on Earth and how it's
shaped our planet in what you'll find is
not very long like of course there was
the dinosaurs the cataclysm 65 million
years ago in the Yucatan but then you
know just in the last 15 000 years you
will be blown away in this episode to
understand the the the changes that
we've experienced on this planet Randall
has been doing his research for over 50
years he's been interested in this since
he was still in high school and has come
to some amazing conclusions through
research as to what's happened on our
planet and what might be coming down the
pipeline and by pipeline I mean from the
sky I hope you enjoy this episode this
will be the first of many I'm sure
please enjoy this one let me know what
you think in the comments of other areas
of Fascination that might apply to
Randall all great athletes have one
thing in common they take care of their
bodies it's something that we do from a
young age whether we work out the food
that we eat how we prepare our mind this
is all part of becoming a great athlete
and one thing that I do every single
morning is I drink ag1 I do it before I
have coffee I do it before I eat any
food I really feel like for me it's
helped my gut health it's made my
stomach just feel like less bloated and
more calm throughout the day it handles
all food so much better I'm putting like
75 high quality ingredients into my body
first thing in the day which makes a
huge difference even if I'm traveling I
use the travel packs I was in Europe for
six weeks every single day I put ag1
into my body so if a comprehensive
solution is what you need from your
supplement routine then ag-1 is giving
you a free one-year supply of vitamin D
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase go to drinkag1.com pretty
intense that's drinkag1.com pretty
intense check it out perfect well I
think then Atlantis is the place to
start then because it seems like did
Lumeria become come before Atlantis in
ancient history
you know we have a really good solid
source for Atlantis which is Plato right
and we can document back when Plato
wrote down the account of Atlantis
probably where he got it lemurray is a
little bit iffier
um now there were land masses in the
Pacific that were certainly habitable
during the Ice Age with the lowered sea
level where those lemuria I don't know I
I suspect that there's some historical
truth behind lemuria
um but I haven't found the kind of
details that Plato gives in his two
dialogues that you can use to attempt to
corroborate whether there could have
actually been a land mass situated
geographically as Plato described
um a lot of the Lemurian stuff has come
from like channeled type information
okay which I don't discount entirely but
I also take it with a pretty generous
dose of skepticism because I've heard so
much of it you know that comes from on
high the ascended masters whatever you
want to call them and it's uh a lot of
it is contradictory a lot of it is just
kind of self-help type stuff kind of
with a kind of some Cosmic
terminology thrown in
um and and so a lot of the lemuria stuff
to me doesn't have the solid basis is
the Atlantis story
and there are references there are there
there
um
they're not
you know overwhelmingly convincing as to
the historical reality of Atlantis but
there are like Pro Plus
um whose original writings are lost was
quoted by krantor later on and
apparently he believed and accepted in
the reality of Atlantis there was
there's basically two schools of thought
Plato in his dialogues makes very clear
oh repeatedly that what he's telling and
recounting is a true tale that it wasn't
made up is it
that it really did exist the
aristotelians came in and said basically
they didn't believe that Atlantis
actually existed and
um and that he meant it as an allegory
for his idea of the idealized political
State and so we've had those kind of two
opposing viewpoints ever since then uh
ever since you know the classical Greek
times
um Plato was what was he roughly three
forty three fifty BC in the socratic
Forum where the the story of Atlantis
was supposedly told so as you come down
through history you have these two
opposing schools of thought one is that
it was an allegory and the other that it
actually existed
so what I did oh gosh this had to have
been 20 25 years ago I had read several
books on Atlantis
um that kind of inspired me to look
further uh there was two books that came
out in the late 79 or 1980.
um one by a German physicist named Otto
Mook who proposed that that Atlantis was
a real place and that it met its demise
because of a an asteroid impact
interestingly this was proposed uh in
1980 the same year that the Alvarez team
and two other teams independently
proposed that that the KT boundary where
the dinosaurs died off was the result of
an impact they found the Iridium layer
first in Italy then I think Denmark then
in New Zealand and then all around the
world iridium is abundant in meteorites
and asteroids it's a very uh scarce on
the surface of the Earth it's
ideirophile which means it bonds with
iron so in the formation of the Earth
all the Iridium bonded with the iron
sank towards the core and therefore left
the surface of the Earth deficient
however it's very abundant in like I
said meteorites and asteroids so finding
an abundant layer of a radium right at
that key boundary where the dinosaurs
disappeared was a huge clue so you had
on the one hand you had the hardcore
scientific Community proposing an idea
that was very controversially at the
time but eventually within a decade
gained acceptance now at that same time
mooc and several others in the late 70s
and early 80s were proposing that
asteroid and Comet impacts had played a
much larger role in Earth history than
had been previously admitted or
recognized see so I read that book and I
thought that was very intriguing that he
was saying that and then there was
another book sir sir Cedric Leonard was
his name um
oh I don't remember the exact name of it
but he he proposed that there had been
evidence of a cataclysm around the time
that Plato placed the uh the subsidence
of Atlantis
and one of the things that he did was he
talked about the Great Pacific Northwest
floods which at that time you know going
back if you know some of the background
stories you know in the 1920s and 1930s
they he's he was a high school geology
uh teacher initially when he started his
research and then he ended up at the end
of his career winning the Penrose medal
which is the highest honor that geology
the geological community bestows on its
members so
um he was eventually Vindicated but only
after this long period of controversy
where he was uh you know defamed and
discredited and and so on anyways he
proposed in the 1920s and 1930s that
there had been these tremendously giant
first a single flood then it got more
complex and it added to the floods out
in the Pacific Northwest
and um
and so anyways in Cedric Leonard's book
he talks about he's talking about
evidence for from around the world very
much like Emmanuel velikovsky did
earlier which was collecting together
evidence geological evidence that there
had been catastrophes in recent Earth
history
um so he had talked about that
particular flooding and as it turned out
uh the year after I got out of high
school in the early 70s I spent the
whole summer traveling around all of the
western states and
inadvertently getting obsessively
interested in geology
like I'm looking at these features and
going there was always something that
struck me about the the textbook
explanations that everything happened
very slowly over millions of years one
grain of sand one drop of water at a
time right so I had this first
impression in actually the summer of
1970 driving through the Columbia Gorge
with a buddy of mine and looking at
these features and just these compelling
features
um some of the tributary rivers to the
Columbia had these gigantic fan Deltas
spread out from their mouth and they
were so huge that that it almost I got
remember getting this impression that I
was almost like uh you know in the in uh
out of Gulliver's Travels or something
and I was in the land of giants oh my
God yeah that's another topic we could
get into yeah
so then I yeah absolutely
um so and then driving back across uh to
my home state where I lived it back then
in Minnesota
we drove across the scablands and at the
time they didn't impress me too much
because I didn't really understand and
didn't see really what was you know we
kind of skirted it
um I didn't see some of these
spectacular features so I read Leonard's
book and he talked about that and I'm
like I remember that yeah I remember
driving you know up to Columbia Gorge
and thinking how incredible a scale of
things was so at that point I really got
interested and I went started spending
well I'd already been spending time in
in libraries they have collections of
the old geological journals I started
going through Harlan bretz's early work
and I would go in and I would get pull
out the journal where there was a
Geological Society of America Journal
whatever it might be I would pull it off
I would read the paper I would photocopy
it and then I would read it reread it
and so I followed all of his work his
first paper on the flooding was 1923.
and his last paper was 1969. and so I
followed you know meticulously through
each of his papers then I read not only
his papers but the critics and yeah I
try to look at both sides yeah with the
younger driest same thing I've read all
of the papers both pro and con for the
younger driest impact hypothesis
you don't know I mean because
there were there were legitimate
criticisms to what brettz was saying
just like our legitimate criticisms to
the younger driest impact hypothesis but
so what I did was and then of course
this is you might know this by now
Danica when you start doing research you
kind of open up multiple rabbit holes I
got very interested in paleo hydrology
which is the study of ancient water
movement as a result of reading brats
but at the same time I got interested in
planetary geology because of the whole
impact phenomena and and I was like
trying to integrate the ideas of mooc
and and Leonard in that Luke was saying
that a six-mile asteroid struck the
Earth at 11 600 years ago which I don't
believe is the scenario anymore
interestingly though at the same time
he's proposing that the Alvarez team is
proposing in the scientific literature
that a six-mile asteroid struck the
Earth 65 million years ago and killed
off the dinosaurs right as I learned
more about the energies and the power of
impacts and things I thought if a six
mile asteroid had struck the Earth 11
600 years ago we wouldn't have recovered
yet you know I grew up in rural
Minnesota
so in rural Minnesota where we live just
Northwest of the Twin Cities was right
at the edge of what is called the
superior lobe of the laurentite ice
sheet which you know that Canada was
covered in a massive a massive ice that
was probably more massive than when you
include both the laurentide ice sheet
and the courtieran together was more
massive than the ice sheet that now
covers the South Pole so it was a huge
amount of ice from the Atlantic to the
Pacific from northern United States up
to the Arctic Circle and it was up to
perhaps a mile and a half thick now that
was still existing 14 15 16 000 years
ago oh my God the time to get rid of
that ice
was before dating like radio carbon
dating and so on
it was imagined that that the period of
necessary to get rid of that much ice
was 50 000 years or a hundred thousand
years see we've we've recently in the
mid 19th century this planet Earth came
out of what is called the little ice age
you may have heard of that term little
Ice Age it was it was the coldest
multi-century period
throughout the entire Holocene which is
the last 11 600 years since the great
Ice Age ended and we can tell from study
of glacial Moorings that that it the the
glaciers worldwide swelled to the
biggest they had been in over 10 000
years right so now what happened with
the birth of glaciology early uh the
early scientists natural philosophers
they were called back then who were
looking and seeing
you know it was well known that the
glaciers had had grown enormously say
between 1400 and and 17 or 1800
um overwhelmed whole Villages were wiped
out Farms were obliterated by the the
hugely growing glaciers wow and so it
became apparent that uh to these early
observers they would watch the the
glaciers then receding which they began
doing and I point this out to people
when they we talk about Glacier
recession is that
the glaciers worldwide had grown to
their largest extent in 11 000 years
roughly and when we start measuring
Glacier recession
we're measuring a process that started
150 years ago or 175 years ago and
started with our Baseline the glaciers
being bigger than they have been like I
said so it's not a fair it's not a fair
metric no it's not it's it's it's an uh
very misleading metric exactly so
anyways by watching the rate of
recession or or decrease in size of the
glaciers
these early researchers
extrapolated to the big glaciers and
they thought okay based on what we've
seen with the with these glaciers
melting back into rates they then
extrapolated backwards and thought well
if your guy to get rid of you know six
million cubic miles of ice which is an
enormous amount of ice covering North
half of North America it's going to take
a long time because for one thing it's
not going to be a linear Continuum it's
you're going to have assuming
and catastrophes weren't really part of
the equation so much then but the idea
is that you're only going to get
seasonal melting and then you're going
to get in the summer the glaciers will
shrink winter will come they'll actually
enlarge again right right so given that
it was assumed that you know you had a
process that might have taken 50 000
years or even longer well now
radiocarbon dating is invented in the
1950s
and by the early 1970s there's 20 years
of data now in hand
so what this data is showing is that
everything went an order of magnitude
quicker than anybody had imagined
in other words you go back 35 000 years
ago in Canada where it was assumed was
completely Frozen locked into the ice
sheet there were forests growing well
then clearly if there were forests
growing right where the the glaciers
were supposed to be at their thickest
right up say around Hudson Bay there
were no glaciers there right so see this
this created a problem and so in 1973
there was a a Conference held
um by a bunch of geologists and
glaciologists and and and people kind of
associated with studying
um the the global change and
there what they did was they tried to
figure out
okay so if if instead of fifty thousand
or a hundred thousand years to get rid
of this huge mass of ice and we're
talking about six million plus cubic
miles of ice
if if okay it didn't take 50 000 years
how long did it take well they came up
with the number of roughly 10 000 years
and so this this created a problem this
is based off of the melting over the
short amount of time they're thinking
that that ratio is consistent even
though it's not yes
yes so so what they then well what that
led them to do was to to realize that in
order to
get rid of that ice would to convert ice
to water
which is what happened it had to convert
can get get converted to water and then
that as it melted it drained off and you
know ocean levels as you may know were
over 400 feet lower during the peak of
the Ice Age now that in itself is a very
interesting
topic to dive into and what the
implications of that are if you drop sea
level by 400 feet what do you think
happens to the coastlines of the world
they're not they're not anywhere near
where they are now are they well I think
coastlines all over the planet and
various different points and times in
history don't always seem consistent
even in my trip to Egypt looking at the
temples and pyramids they they were all
met by the river the Nile now they're
nowhere close the denial is never close
and you know there are old maps of
Antarctica being completely vegetative
and there is green and plants and
whether that's true or not obviously
coastlines in and climate have evolved
and changed absolutely of course of this
planet's history to a complete degree
like not a very a complete like hot cold
cold to hot yes water to dry
yes the the planet we live on is is way
more Dynamic than anybody was even
imagining a generation ago and when you
get and I'm going to come back to the to
these conferences in the early 70s but
I'll digress for a minute and I'll say
that
in the in the global warming scenarios
they basically are coming out of the
1980s before we had like satellite
surveys of Shifting sea levels uh before
we were uh recording variable output of
the Sun for example there were no solar
stand lights looking at the sun in 1988
when global warming was first proposed
so it became very easy to dismiss or
ignore the role of the sun into computer
models right well we know a whole lot
more about the sun now than we did back
then right so what what every single
front of scientific research into Earth
history
confirms that that history of this
planet is extraordinarily Dynamic and is
subject to all kinds of changes which
brings us back to these early
conferences in 1973 where they got
together and they looked at the rate at
which the ice sheet melted and they said
okay
you have to have energy from somewhere
yeah to convert the ice to water
and so they struggled mightily to come
up with a source and they couldn't do it
so at the end of that conference they
they referred to it as the energy
Paradox and they said well put it on the
shelf so two out two years later in 1975
a follow-up Conference was held
they took another look at the data the
only thing that had changed in those two
years was even the time span had even
compressed further
and even there if you're thinking eight
or ten thousand years to get rid of the
ice you're still thinking of a smooth
linear Continuum not a thing that we
know now with the younger driest for
example at 1300 years the melting
process was not only stopped it was
probably reversed and so you had this
period of Rapid melting followed by this
rapid shift back into major glacial cold
and then you had this regrowth of the
ice sheet so
um so what has happened is it we're
confronted with this Paradox that nobody
came up with the idea of where did the
energy come from this was the nobody
came up
um and and they said there must be an
error in the data somewhere
um but when you read these papers from
the early 70s you can just see that
they're scratching your heads trying to
figure out how do we explain such a
rapid disappearance of glacial ice
compared to what we're calling you know
things that we don't understand in the
universe dark energy and dark matter we
just give it a cool name and call it up
and go give it a name yeah there it is
DNA yeah but see now since what happened
was in in my own research I came to the
conclusion that the most likely source
of energy was some kind of a cosmic
impact now this was back in the in the
early 90s
I heard about this these features near
where I live called the Carolina Bays
and the Carolina bays are this series of
elliptical formations there's tens of
thousands of them
um on the coastal plain of of North and
South Carolina Georgia they're
elliptical and and they I mean in this
at the on the edge of the water it's
sort of like a they start explosion it's
it's like imagine a shallow
lake or swamp that's elliptical shaped
okay
and there were thousands of them and the
the first they were first discovered in
1930s uh with the first aerial surveys
of the southeastern United States during
the Roosevelt administration oh wow
that's so interesting even in and of
itself the fact that the 1930s is the
aerial observation but you know we've
had like you know images of the planet
and the countries and the I mean there's
so many things that we've had for so
much longer and it's like where'd those
come from
yeah well see nobody knew about them
because
um you from the ground you don't really
see him it's when you get above and you
look down that you can see these
features and how amazing they are and
and they are really
um you know I just went to you heard
about a couple of months ago there was
the cosmic Summit in Nashville did you
hear about that okay so there was
um my friend Chris Cottrell has been
studying the Carolina Bays for years so
he did a really interesting presentation
on their origin and there's multiple
theories as to their origin I still lean
towards a multiple impact event you know
you've heard of the tunguska event of
1908 the the the explosion over Siberia
no oh Danica you need to know about this
this was like okay this is like the
cause the cosmos giving us flicking us
going hey but you better pay attention
because there's bigger things happening
here so in 1908 early uh on the date
that coincides to our June 30th early in
the morning sun is just coming up
it's up near Lake Baikal
um a Heavenly Body brighter than the sun
came through the atmosphere and then
descending towards the Earth at a high
rate of speed and at five roughly five
miles above the surface of the ground it
exploded
and the shock wave went out and it
devastated over 800 square miles of old
growth taiga forest it had the estimates
are that it released energies roughly
equivalent to 15 Megaton hydrogen bomb
Oh my God so okay wow that would create
a lot of heat yeah it would and it did
create a lot of heat so
there was over 80 million huge old
growth trees that were just snapped off
like twigs
splayed out where it's from the
epicenter underwear this thing exploded
and
um it was not even discovered for almost
20 years later before scientists got
there because it was so remote but the
villagers when they they get there the
the tangusi tribes people that lived
there had a whole new religion
spawned by this by this event
um in the area over which it exploded
was Contin was considered to be accursed
so when uh lyanna tulik who was the
first scientist Russian scientist to get
to the air because the rumors had been
coming out for years that something
extraordinary had happened now to give
you an idea if you take uh Phoenix the
area of Phoenix or any Metropolitan
you're in near Phoenix right yep okay
picture this a 15 Megaton hydrogen bomb
800 square miles would utterly
obliterate the entire metropolitan area
of Phoenix
so this is what this is the scale of
this thing right
well so lyanna Kulik got there nearly 20
years later and he mounted this Ridge
where he could look out
in front of him and he could see this
whole region of devastated Forest that
was still the trees are still splayed
out from the from the epicenter under
the epicenter itself there are about 200
square miles that were completely
incinerated sure it was just nothing
nothing it was just a big
they can land but it was already
starting to recover
um when he got there but you could still
see they you can you can figure out that
it was roughly about 200 square miles
that was incinerated 800 plus square
miles where the the power of the the
blast was probably 20 or 30 PSI enough
that would knock buildings over
um and the pressure wave moved out from
that epicenter so anyways scientists are
still studying the 10 Goose they're
mostly killed things though it didn't
necessarily like level buildings but it
would be enough to
um kill anything alive yes and luckily
there were no people living there there
were people living under periphery who
witnessed the thing and those eyewitness
accounts are extraordinary what these
people witnessed I mean there were
people 30 miles away who were like blown
20 and 30 feet you know were sitting on
their front porch in the blast wave
moved across and they were like
literally
thrown off their seats or knocked off
their I mean this is 30 miles from the
epicenter
um and people described it as being
brighter than the sun
um and the interesting thing to me about
it that I I have my own opinion about
what it was there's many different
opinions but there's a there's a meteor
stream called the torrid meteor stream
that the Earth crosses twice each year
we crossed that thing twice each year we
cross it twice one of the people yeah
there's a there's a
um there's a a fall time crossing of the
stream which actually Peaks right around
Halloween and I've actually I put
together a whole discussion about the
origin of Halloween that I uh put up
last year Halloween actually is a very
deep ritualized celebration that we do
that has that goes back literally
thousands of years to the universal Day
of the Dead
and it's been been commemorated the same
time of year all over the planet
interestingly is commemorated right at
the time of the Fall time Torrid meteor
stream
um picture an elliptical orbit right and
this stream is going out to Jupiter
coming back around the Sun and making
this orbit meanwhile Earth crosses that
stream twice in the fall and then again
in the summer at the end of June and
early July now in the fall we're
crossing the stream when it's coming in
and if you look Upstream you're actually
looking out into space
towards the constellation of Taurus
hence the the torrid media stream and
almost precisely you're actually looking
at the What's called the radiant point
where all of these meteors appear to be
emanating
from that point it almost is like
bullseye on the Pleiades which is the
shoulder of the bull
so now it's a very interesting mythology
about the Pleiades the the bull of
Heaven and the Gilgamesh for example
fighting the bull of heaven and and we
won't get into that today but that
subject matter for another discussion
very interesting stuff anyways the
stream comes in it goes around the Sun
in What's called the perihelion passage
which is when that stream comes as close
to the Sun as it ever does in its orbit
it then is coming from around behind the
Sun and that is where so when when the
earth crosses that stream
um in the summertime we're seeing that
material those meteors they're now
coming from behind the Sun so we're
looking towards the Sun so in other
words they're very difficult to see if
at all
during the summer because again we're
looking towards the sun
whereas during the fall you're looking
away from the Sun you're looking out
towards the constellation getting a
reflection from the Sun now on those as
opposed to being blinded by the sun yeah
you're looking yes that's exact that's
right so
um
so anyways the region of space from
which the object came now there was you
know hundreds of eyewitnesses and they
basically you know said well it came
from that that part of space and they
pointed to this region some people said
it looked like it was being uh disgorged
from the Sun others said it looked like
it was uh you know being born out of the
Sun that kind of thing so
as a result of that you know the
astronomers have been able to
reconstruct with pretty good degree of
accuracy where that radiant point in
space was in other words if you were to
look in the sky when that thing came in
which direction were you looking so now
both the direction that the thing came
in from and the time of year are
consistent with it being a member of the
torrid meteor stream and so I I lean
towards that I think the evidence is
strongest that it is a member of that
and it's likely that the torrid meteor
stream is the remnant of a gigantic
Comet that came into the inner solar
system and began this sort of this ping
pong game between the Sun and Jupiter
around between 25 and 30 000 years ago
then begin to undergo a series of
fragmentation events that spawned
several cometary nuclei and several
media streams and it's been proposed by
a number of strong astronomers now that
it was probably an encounter with the
torrid meteor stream was the most likely
candidate for triggering the younger
driest impact
would it make a difference coming off of
Jupiter being a maybe a more consistent
gravity than coming off of the sun with
solar flares have some influence on the
the media the the stream staying in
uniform sort of trajectory as opposed to
having other influences well Jupiter of
course is a massive gravitational field
which can deflect objects oftentimes
when comets are coming in now the the
meteors are the spawn of comets
comets come in from their reservoirs
outside of Neptune the Kuiper disc or
even outside that the ort cloud and
there's a whole interesting discussion
how that process happens but
um Kuiper disc is this generally it's
it's a series of billions of comets that
lay into the orbital plane of the the
planets the the the uh the plane of the
ecliptic
conjunctions of the big outer planets
can sometimes
disrupt these objects these cometary
objects that are in a quasi-stable orbit
what that means is that there's slowly
this whole disc is slowly rotating the
sun right so each of the individual
comets is making this long you know
hundreds of thousands or millions of
years to make this long journey around
the Sun they're part of the solar system
conjunctions of the outer planets Uranus
and Neptune can when they combined can
disrupt
the stability of the cometary orbits on
the inner flanks of that Kuiper disc and
if you can picture
um almost a slingshot phenomena if this
comet is moving through space now here
come the two planets with their combined
gravitational field let's say they find
the comet so what they're doing is is
their their gravity field is acting to
slow down to break like put the brakes
on well when that happens the comet then
loses energy and it begins to migrate
sunward the reverse of that is if the
comet is behind and you've got the
gravitational
field of the two outer planets Uranus
and Neptune they can accelerate the
comet well then the comet then tends to
move to a higher higher energy level
and it moves away from the Sun it turns
out that the four big outer planets
Jupiter Saturn Uranus and Neptune are
exactly precisely spaced according to
their masses that would be necessary if
you're going to create this handoff this
bucket for great gain of handing comets
from the their zone out there in the
Kuiper disc to actually sending them
sunward when they come sunward it's like
when you're out there in the Kuiper disc
they're in they're in deep freeze it's
like they're in hibernation
as they move sunward they become active
right and then yeah exactly then they
start coming apart and and what they
might make multiple loops around the Sun
and each time they come close to the Sun
or close to Jupiter the the strong
gravity of those two objects will
further disrupt the coherence of the
cometary nucleus and eventually what
happens is that nucleus disintegrates
into a meteor stream
hmm and you know and it's named after
the point in space
where it appears that the meteors are
emanating from so the towards like I
said if you if you go out on
um Halloween and you stand and you you
face Taurus the Bull which happens to be
in the northern hemisphere due south
right and you're standing in your face
and you find the Pleiades and you focus
on the because the Pleiades culminate
right at midnight on Halloween
coincidentally so if you look at though
that Spain region in space that's where
you will see the meteors appearing to
shoot out from right that's the radiant
point
now leonids
named after Leo because if you look at
the Leonid shower you're looking towards
the uh very close to the star regulus
which is actually like the shoulder of
the lion uh the Geminids
associated with Gemini the draconids
associated with with Draco so that's how
they get their names they're not
actually coming from Draco or Leo or
Taurus they're just in that meteor
they're in that zone where if you're
look imagine if you've ever up down
railroad tracks and you see how they
yeah you know they're parallel but they
give the illusion they're very
encouraging yeah that's kind of what
yeah it's almost like you're looking up
a tunnel when you're looking at a meteor
shower how do they ever get the names
then in the first place like what what
drove the names then and when how old
are those names
uh for the constellations yeah but but
even before the constellation sounds
like came the meteor stream that is that
is in that area
well
that's which one came first
which one came first well what came
first was the constellations okay the
the zodiacal constellations if you look
at these Gemini Taurus now Draco not is
not part of the the Zodiac belt but Leo
Gemini it's got to be something angry
for Aries I mean we're really we're
really aggressive so there's got to be
some aggressive meteor
stream out there well they're the
Heritage are called so-called and they
are probably like an offspring of the
torrids wow because you know Taurus and
Aries are next to each other yeah so
when you have this splitting that occurs
what will happen is each object of the
initial object it breaks up now you've
got two nuclei let's say that further
breaks up but as they're traveling they
will separate
so now what it appears is the Heritage
are a cousin to the torrids and probably
if you go back they all stemmed from
that original progenitor Comet which
would have been a huge cometary nucleus
50 to 100 miles in diameter so is this
is this
um
to these
passes their cycle to these cataclysms
and what would the consist whatever the
common denominator be in in the in the I
do believe yes it looks to me like the
evidence is pointing quite strongly to
there being a periodicity to these
events here's how I this is what I liken
it to
um imagine which I'm sure you can do
well you've got a racetrack with a lot
of cars going around at a high rate of
speed and you've got a road that cuts
right across the middle of it right now
initially dangerous yeah so now you've
got let's say you've got a cluster of
cars that are that are clumped together
or spread out uniformly
now that's going to affect let's say
that you know you're just you've got
this big elliptical race track the cars
are racing around it and you've got a
road cutting right across the middle of
it so as you're driving along you know
uh like I like to drive in the country
because there's very little traffic and
I can put some music on and I can kick
back and kind of relax which is totally
different from driving into heavy
traffic in Atlanta but now think of it
think of it this way this is the analogy
I use so if you're driving along there's
on this country road there's no traffic
but now the road intersects the
racetrack right and so now while you're
crossing the racetrack and there's no
stop signs there's no red lights or any
of that so you're just going through
blindly well obviously what happens is
when you're Crossing that the
probabilities or possibilities of there
being a catastrophic impact increase
considerably right now further let's say
that all of the cars are clumped pretty
much together
so if they're
down on one area of the track maybe your
probabilities are low if you're coming
through
when the clump is right there now your
probabilities are high sure does that
make sense yeah for sure but it hit but
we come we come into we we come into
orbit with this twice a year yes we do
we don't have two cataclysms a year no
no no we don't because most of the time
we come through we're lucky and we we
miss this would have not been the case
thousands of years ago because
originally when this Comet begins to
break apart
the debris of that comet is going to be
concentrated in certain areas within its
orbit now over thousands of years that
debris will will spread out and become
more uniformly distributed throughout
the the entire path of the uh orbital
path right yeah early on if if if that
cometary nucleus is in the early stages
of breaking up there will be periods
where there are much more dangerous than
other periods if we're crossing if we're
crossing larger clumps too larger clumps
too so it hasn't broken up either so
correct something that comes through and
burns up in the atmosphere and turns
into some sort of blast as opposed to an
impact is going to be a lot less damaged
too yes and and like tunguska was about
150 feet in diameter that's the
estimates roughly about the same size
have you ever been over to meteor crater
by Winslow well you're it's right there
in your neck of the woods Danica out
this is one of your assignments now is
to go to Media Creator okay
um you of course heard the Eagle song
standing on the corner in Winslow
Arizona okay well it's just it's a Well
such a sight to see is meteor crater
which is just a few miles from Winslow
and uh go there stand on the edge of
that and look down in this massive
gaping hole in the ground uh you know 3
500 feet across 600 feet deep and then
imagine that what you're looking at is
an impact of a just a cosmic Speck a
baby interestingly meteor crater was an
iron object which is high density you
know maybe five grams per cubic Cent
imagine you're holding a piece of cast
iron the Cusco event was much lower it
was probably a piece of a comet nucleus
like I said which is going to be lower
density which is going to be maybe a
gram two grams per cubic imagine an ice
cube
okay so that's the difference
cast iron and an ice cube and a full a
Continuum of stuff in between from one
end of that Continuum to the other right
the meteor crater in Arizona was an iron
object that was able to fully penetrate
the atmosphere and strike the ground
whereas the tungusk object was lower
density
it almost like a belly flop into a
swimming swimming pool the fluid of the
atmosphere could not move out of the way
in time and it just essentially
compressed in front of it and once it
reached about five miles
above the surface it it just exploded so
a lower density object is going to
explode in the atmosphere
up to a certain size and then once you
get big enough everything's going to hit
the earth directly media crater was
produced by an object roughly the same
size
but an iron object struck the Earth such
an event happened today you would
crop Phoenix would I believe be
destroyed by the the impact blast moving
out from the epicenter but you should
know livelihood of this happening again
in the near future well let's put it
this way two weeks ago a couple of weeks
ago let's see July 14th
an object two and a half times the mass
of tunguska came less than a quarter of
the distance
to the Moon
now that's a very very close shave now
that would not be a planetary
catastrophe
but if you figure this if tunguska had
and I did the calculations on this if
taguska had the uh energy of a 15
Megaton hydrogen bomb and other other
things being equal and this was a uh a
two and a half times the mass and it was
probably more than that because it was
an asteroid so it would have been
heavier right probably three times to
four times the density of tunguska
if that thing had actually come just a
slightly different angle than it did and
it hit the earth it would have been
enough to I did a calculation it could
have completely wiped out
um say an area the size of the state of
Delaware
it would have been probably around 2 500
square miles devastated and it was it
was about 45 megatons of 50 megatons of
energy which is about the same as the
largest hydrogen bomb ever tested by
humans back in 1962 when the Soviet
Union tested Tsar Bamba which was
50 estimated 50 megatons would there be
a ripple effect from even that that the
entire planet would know about or could
this stuff be happening that doesn't
really pop up on our radar because
nobody's there well think of if you go
back to uh February of what was the 2013
Chelyabinsk you had a object much
smaller than tunguska that exploded over
that Village of Chelyabinsk and um
15 around 1500 people were injured quite
grievously in some cases to my knowledge
nobody was killed but several thousand
buildings were you know glass windows
were blown in
um you know trees were toppled and
things like that so and this was just a
very small piece and it and it exploded
like I think like 12 or 14 miles up in
the atmosphere
so the thing is that there are you know
the Department of Defense has been
tracking these things for decades I bet
and if you had a tunguska event let's
say coming in over the ocean
and exploding we probably wouldn't know
it other than you know if you've ever
heard of some of the super waves I've
sometimes thought that these anomalous
large waves that have been documented
might be the result of that kind of an
event
um but yeah we would certainly know it
if if these days if if a tunguska event
happened anywhere on the planet we would
know it and of course we're much densely
more densely populated now if if a
tanguska event happened now let's say
over the Eastern Seaboard you would have
at least a couple of million casualties
at least
um and if this event uh from uh from
July
14th to just happened if that thing had
had hit the Earth yeah it would have
been a major Game Changer
um so I don't think anything like that
has happened there is evidence that in
the 1930s there was a multiple impact
event in Brazil
that was close to the scale of tunguska
maybe not quite as damaging or
destructive or as powerful but again
because it was remote
um the the the accounts of it are you
know pretty sparse uh and and then the
area that was destroyed
in the rain forest is so quickly
recovered that it became difficult to
make studies after the fact
so I think that that we can look at you
know there's there's a number of proxies
we can use to reconstruct ancient
climate change and and things like that
um ice cores uh uh sea bottom sediment
cores
um you know pollen and seeds and plants
that accumulate let's say in lakes and
ponds I mean there's all kinds of ways
that we can reconstruct you know tree
rings a great way of reconstructing
ancient climate change
the data in hand to me looks very much
like it's
going towards some kind of cycles that
this does and and see and here's the
thing that might be confusing going back
to the analogy of the road going across
the racetrack
what would be consistent is that every
time you're going across that
the vulnerability
increases by maybe in order several
orders of magnitude and the periodicity
would be consistent that you could say
okay just like
um you know you if you say when you know
growing up in Minnesota we always like
when is going to be the first freeze of
the year
um when it's when it's the first thaw
gonna be you know and usually it's
within a one one or two weeks of the the
usual date okay
but what I'm getting at here is that in
this case
um even though you you can say with a
high degree of of precise timing when
the periods of vulnerability occur that
doesn't necessarily mean that there's
going to be a cataclysm you see what I'm
saying it all depends on the luck of the
draw when you're Crossing that Highway
whether there's other cars coming
um now you're if if you picture you've
got the the racetrack and then you've
got a big circle and you're driving
around that Circle and every time you
come around that Circle you're you're
crossing the track your vulnerability
goes up but it doesn't necessarily mean
100 of the time that you're going to get
hit right right we might think of it as
being so vulnerable you know twice a
year or something like you think oh
we're coming into contact with it but it
might be just sort of like a you know
like a flip of a coin there's a there's
a certain ratio for heads or tails and
so it's it's kind of like we're looking
at it through the lens of danger every
time but maybe based on the size and the
gravity and the elements that maybe some
of them we don't really understand is
that there's actually the risk is far
smaller essentially and it might only
happen every
twelve thousand years or twenty six
thousand years or whatever it may be
well and interestingly there does seem
to be
um a cycle a period that looks like it's
around both of those 12 and 26 000 of
course the younger driest is now dated
about 12 000 younger driest impact
stated about 12 850 years ago which is
almost exactly half of Earth's
processional cycle
there's a book that came out in 19
fractal everything is so fragile yes it
very much very much we live in a fractal
universe and it's fractal not only I
believe in terms of space but in time as
well
and this is a very interesting
discussion we should have at some point
Danica about some of the some of these
Traditions that have come down to us
um what I'm very interested in is this
convergence of ancient knowledge and
ancient wisdom and understanding of how
nature worked and our place in it and
the modern Concepts and to me the
realization is that they're very
complementary and in fact are converging
on each other and we're realizing that
the legacy of ancient stories and myths
and folklore and legends and all of this
stuff is is a very potent source of real
information
circling back to the tunguska thing I
mentioned that there was a it spawned a
new religion
okay well when you go and you begin to
read some of the ancient stories like
when when Plato we started this
conversation with Atlantis when Plato
opens to maeus his first of the two
dialogues on Atlantis what is the very
first thing that he dives into is the
myth of Satan
and Satan was the story of the son of
Helios who grew up not knowing whose
father was and when he would go to
school all of his classmates would
always be bragging about all the great
things that their fathers were doing and
this and that and poor fate and he
didn't know who his father was fateen
goes to his mother begs her to to tell
him who's my father and she says well
your father actually is the
the grandest of all of them it's he's
Helios the Sun God and so Satan makes it
his life's mission to seek out his
father which he does and he gets to the
great palace where the sun god resides
and our
there are Gates there are these huge
Gates and he goes in and if you read
Greek mythology the the the the gods and
goddesses of Mythology have all of these
powers and things that they can do
you know that that differentiate them
from us mere mortals but one of the
things that they're Bound by is if they
make a promise they are compelled to
keep the promise so fate
heliosis Overjoyed to see his son that
he says I will grant you any Boon that
you wish and Satan says well I want to
drive your chariot I want to drive the
Chariot of the Sun
so fate and I mean so Helios goes well
uh wait a minute I meant anything except
that so then as the as the myth unfolds
Helios does everything he can to
persuade
not to drive to drive the charity to the
Sun
okay finally he has to relinquish Satan
gets into Chariot and there's four great
steeds that are pulling the chariot
the gates open The Chariot flies out and
immediately these powerful Steve's
steeds realize that whoever is holding
the reins
is not up to the task and they their
normal course which it describes in the
myth would be the the plane of the
ecliptic with the signs of the zodiac
The Chariot veers off of the normal path
of the sun descends down to earth and
sets the Earth on fire mm-hmm now first
thing that Plato says is he opens his
story of Atlantis by recounting the myth
of fate
and he says this has the appearance of a
myth but it's not a myth he says it
right out
unambiguously says what it really
represents is the body circling in
heaven and the decline of one of those
bodies down to the Earth so he's clearly
describing a meteor or an asteroid and
later commentators agreed that yes Satan
must have been a memory of some kind of
a Cosmic Encounter it's interesting to
me
that he prefaces his whole account of
Atlantis with that myth I would Plato
know that's my question then is how
would Plato know and you know I feel
like I've heard that there that Atlantis
was knocked out but there were survivors
and those survivors were the ones that
started
come at and started Egypt they were the
original original original
indigenous people of Egypt yeah so I
people were always asking me about
Atlantis so I decided Well okay I'm
gonna put out my thoughts on Atlantis it
turned into a 10 and a half hour lecture
something like that over over several
parts
um I live streamed it out a couple of
years ago
um and what I did is I've gone through
Plato's account four different five
different translations including the
original Greek in order to correlate you
know the words that he were translated
as island did they really mean Island
right right right so on so I've got in
fact right sitting here next to me I've
got my Greek dictionary
um oh my God so I I procured a the
original Greek translation of tameus and
critius and went through them line by
line
read four like I said four or five
different translations so I could get
the different nuances and stuff from how
different translators so and this this
was like when I first did this going
back to the stories that I said early
80s when I read those couple of books on
Atlantis which which led me ultimately
to the ultimate source of Atlantis which
is Plato
so
what I did was Plato gives some very
explicit details in terms of the
geography the geology the astronomy the
oceanography all of that stuff so what I
did was I thought to myself okay I'm
going to do just a a thought experiment
here and I'm gonna I'm gonna imagine
that
somehow whatever Plato you know and he
says in there repeatedly throughout the
dialogues this is real this is true I'm
not making this up right so he gives the
the the the lineage ultimately from
solon's Journey to Egypt which occurred
roughly around 600 BC a couple of
hundred years before Plato and
he gives the succession between
um Solon and drupidis and these in his
offspring and how it eventually got down
to critias and then critius presented it
at the socratic Forum where Plato heard
it and wrote it down okay so but the
interesting thing that caught my
attention early on and because I had
already now become familiar with
catastrophism I did not yet know about
the younger driest this is in the 80s
right
um I didn't know about the younger
driest until the 90s
um younger driest was identified long
before an impact event was proposed as
its trigger because they saw in Europe
that there was these extraordinary
climate changes that occurred at this
particular Horizon so so but one of the
things that Plato's three times he gives
the the sort of the chronology and he
says that when Solon went to Egypt the
elderly priests that he talked to told
him about this ancient history that had
happened 9 000 years earlier
and so they talked about this great war
between this Atlantean Empire that was a
group of islands plural in the
Mid-Atlantic west of the pillars of
Hercules and they were originally very
highly evolved and very spiritual but
then they degenerated and they became
imperialistic and they came in and
invaded the Nations inside the pillars
of Hercules which is the Straits of
Gibraltar which is the mouth that
separates the Mediterranean from the
Atlantic Ocean
so they came in and they began
subjugating and enslaving and then the
what I call the the
proto-athenians the the people that
occupied the Greek Peninsula according
to this account now they rallied and
organized everybody and there was this
great war between the the the the groups
the cultural groups inside the
Mediterranean against the atlanteans
that had come from outside and
immediately after this war there was a
great catastrophe
tremendous rainfall fell over Greece and
there was a massive he talks about this
in in the dialogue a massive severe
erosional event over Greece that wiped
out their army and likewise there was a
series of earthquakes that caused the
Atlantic Island Islands to subside and
this all according to the story in the
Egyptian priest happened nine thousand
years
before so long
Solon was 2600 years ago so do the math
twelve thousand some years 11 600 which
is precisely the end of the younger
driest
precisely a major climate shift happened
a catastrophic climate change and also
precisely the date of what is called
melt water pulse 1B when there was a
massive melting of the great ice sheets
and a huge influx of water and a rapid
rise of sea level
yeah all of this happening precisely on
the date that Plato gives if you look up
the Holocene right now and look it up
you'll see that it's usually dated at 11
600 11 700 years ago and there's this
major
point of transition the end of the 1300
year spell of the younger driest I think
that there was probably a secondary
impacts at the end or it was maybe the
sun I think we're looking at the at the
end of the last ice age I think we're
looking at a perfect storm
one of the things a question you asked
earlier that I didn't address because we
kind of in our long-ranging discussion
here there's evidence that the in-fall
of comets into the sun it might be
connected with solar storms and coronal
mass ejections okay
so it could be that if there was a major
influx of cometary mass
this gigantic comet is coming in
breaking up spawning you know these
families of of of uh Offspring and some
of these are most of the cometary
material that comes in does end up being
swallowed up by the sun and it could be
some of the evidence seems to show a
correlation between the info
there's actually a whole family of
comets called the kreutz Sun grazers
and even a small object falling into the
chromosphere of the sun seems to trigger
coronal mass ejections and solar storms
well it's energy coming in and then
energy going out yes that's right so
there could be a connection then that if
you have a large comma coming into the
inner solar system breaks up large
masses of that fall into the sun the sun
responds and so we might be looking at
not only impacts but
um solar events now there's an
interesting controversy and disagreement
between Robert shock and Graham Hancock
right you know who those two guys are
okay Robert shock is solidly on the sign
of a solar event Graham is pretty solid
on the side of an impact event whereas
I'm staying in the middle going I think
it could have been both
we know that the evidence for an impact
at 12
850 years ago at the beginning of the
younger guys is very robust
we have evidence now from half of the
more than half the planet
signature of an impact event
but what happened at the end of the
younger that was the cooling and that
would have been the cooling that was the
cooling and then at the end of the
younger Grice there was an extremely
rapid warming
extremely rapid
um anomalously rapid mysteriously rapid
and we don't know what happened there
and to my knowledge we don't have hard
evidence of an impact like we do at the
beginning of the younger driest so it
could have been the sun I'm totally open
to that now I think Graham I I think
I've heard that Robert may not be as
opposed to the impact ideas he once was
um and that Graham may not be quite as
opposed to the sun idea the solar
component is I don't know if he was ever
really against it but he was definitely
on the side of an impact event
so right what about the impact in
um Mexico and the Yucatan what is that
date at well that's the that's the
Cretaceous tertiary boundary that's the
dinosaur killer there's very interesting
stories we could get into about that and
what the Mayans may have known you know
one number that obviously was so far off
was the age of the universe and having
sort of doubled essentially from 13 odd
billion to 26 I billion years old and so
I'm wondering about just sort of you
know the science and technology used to
date things and and what what uh what
you think about
such an epic fail essentially and and
how you feel about numbers like 65 000
65 million years or 12 000 years is it
seem
reliable the dating of of geological
straight is going to be a little
different than the dating of the
universe and in geology we have relative
dating
um and we have absolute dating now
relative dating is basically this if
you've got a flood which let's say comes
in and puts down a layer of deposits or
you have a volcanic eruption and you
have a layer of Ash or lava and then
after a while
ferns which are the first colonizer
plants like if you go to Mount St Helens
or any catastrophe ferns tend to be the
first colonizer plant that comes back in
the in the wake of a catastrophe that
devastates the ecosystem and then those
ferns go through several life cycles and
they provide the the basic Matrix for
higher succession plants to to take root
and generally it'll take about a
millennia for to get let's say from a
from a Barren landscape like you would
have out in the aftermath of the Mount
St Helens eruption to when you've got
mature forests growing there right but
now when you look at geological evidence
for example we know that carbonate rocks
like limestones dolomites they form in
oceans they show up form in Shallow Seas
right
um we know sandstones can form either
from the sand of beaches or the sand of
deserts how do we tell the difference
well because beaches will have a
different
morphology than deserts deserts if you
look at a sandstone outcrop and if we
ever do a field trip and you're on one
of my field trips I will show you
outcrops of sandstone where you can and
you will quickly learn to differentiate
between Sands that were deposited by
water and Sands that were deposited by
wind so by looking at the strata of
sandstone now typically imagine this
Danica you've got we talked about ocean
levels rising and falling so imagine
that we've got ocean levels where they
are now and we go into another Ice Age
now all of that water is being extracted
from the ocean deposited on the land
mass in the form of ice where it's
locked up that causes sea levels to
decline which causes the coastlines to
migrate seaward well as as sea level is
falling you've got this shallow Marine
imagine that most of the coastal shelves
of the planet off the planks of the
continent are less than 400 feet in
depth so that means large quads of the
Continental shelves are now exposed all
the coral reefs everything are they're
going to die right
um
now as the the land as the ocean is
receding the beach is moving seaward so
you can actually track that right and
then as the the beach is moving see
we're like where I live here in Georgia
if I go stand on the coastline now and
I'm standing there at the beach right
and all of a sudden I'm transported back
15 000 years ago to the late glacial
maximum I ain't on the beach anymore I'm
50 miles Inland and I'm standing in the
middle of a forest right it's so crazy
it's just not that long ago no it's not
it's not at all because for one thing
it's in the well within the time that we
humans have been on the planet right so
our ancestors lived through these
changes but here's what I'm getting at
so the sea level goes down now you've
got forests growing and and we find the
evidence of forests drowned all right
sure 200 feet in you know from where you
were exactly 25 miles into the ocean
right so now sea level rises and what
happens is those areas get drowned and
now you have all the little creatures
that make their shells out of calcium
carbonate right and they die and they
filter to the bottom and they form
layers of limestone now we know we can
track the rate at which those that
bedding forms on the sea bottom right
right now you find a layer of limestone
that's uh a thousand two thousand feet
thick you know that is a long long
period of time of deposition and then it
gives way to let's say shales or shales
form generally out of Muddy Water
shales so so as the sea level is going
down and you've got the swampy coastal
areas migrating along with it now what
will happen is the limestones will have
shales over them you'll have limestones
then you'll have sandstones that were
formed by the beach and then you'll have
shales over that then you may have who
knows like in the Columbia Basalt
Plateau where these great floods happen
there are dozens of layers of flooding
that occurred over a period of uh
roughly 10 million years but sandwiched
in between some of these lava flows are
the remains of whole forests
right so you know from these kinds of
things that there had to be a long span
of time and if you've got a layer of
limestone Sandstone shale
maybe some other stuff maybe maybe some
volcanic deposits and then another layer
of limestone another layer of Shannon
you've got this thousands
quite well right now we've got
radiometric dating which is being
improved all the time and here's the
thing the radiometric dating is more or
less
correlated with the relative dating
so in other words we can assume okay if
here's the rates of deposition in a
shallow marine environment for
limestones and if the limestones are
this thick
okay it how long did it take so now you
can get an approximate idea of the
passage of time now you come in with the
various types of radiometric dating and
there's half a dozen different ways of
dating the half-lives of you know
viranium of thorium
of these kinds of things
and those more or less
correlate and complement the relative
data right so it's like they're at least
in the same order of magnitude
so what that does is it kind of builds
our confidence that that that they're
correct yeah yeah okay that makes sense
yeah um Let me throw another timeline at
you I know we kind of jumped away from
the dinosaurs um but I just want to add
one more to this sort of orbital Loop
sort of theme we have going on and I'm
curious
about
the orbit of Nibiru and the Anunnaki
stories and and and if I think it's what
3 600 years or something like that is
this sort of orbital Loop of Nibiru
coming through and that being somehow
some kind of uh there's a there's a
consistent pattern in a in a in a in an
evolutionary genetic upgrade with human
beings
thoughts
that was an idea that was actually
proposed by mainstream scientists 20 and
30 years ago that there was this extra
Solar Planet
right now it was Zechariah sitchin in
the 80s came up with the idea of this
3600 year cycle I I read a bunch of his
work and thought it was very interesting
but I thought at the same time I'm going
to wait and see I need some hard
evidence before I
before I go along with this
um I haven't seen it yet
now third evidence of the planet having
of the plant or hard evidence of
um
well there's hard evidence of
catastrophes No Doubt
and I've done a tremendous amount of
work of trying to correlate setting up a
timeline of various catastrophes going
back several hundred thousand years yeah
I mean that'd be fascinating being a
fractal fractal universe and or where
there's a rhythm to everything you you
know it could be quite quite the profit
there yeah so I don't know about that
Danica I'm just you know I'm I'm not
going to sign on and I'm not going to
reject it there could be something out
there I mean there's tantalizing
evidence suggesting that there might be
something an extra solar type object out
there I'm more inclined to believe that
that there's something that periodically
dis like we talked about earlier
something that periodically disrupts the
stability of that social comments and
then it sends this sort of cascading
um phenomena of comets moving towards
the Sun what seems so crazy is that
there's these ancient stories structures
there's there's so many things that we
don't completely understand is it more
likely that there is extraterrestrial
influence or is it that we continue to
face these cataclysmic events that
create essentially a great reset that
reset the the planet from an
evolutionary standpoint than it is that
we get outside help okay so that is a
really interesting question that opens
up a huge deep Rabbit Hole might be
beyond the scope of today's conversation
okay that's okay all right we'll just
touch it
uh uh say this you use the term great
reset which I think is a very apropos
term because
apparently you you think about this
Danica we modern humans you know that
assume with the same cranial capacity
same bone structure in every way pretty
much identical to Modern people
180 000 years or even 200 000 years
old skeletons and remains found it
looked like that long ago there were
modern humans
on the Earth
now let's just take the round number 200
000 years I mean how many generations is
that
200 000 years that's that's an
extraordinary number of people that
could have potentially lived on earth
you're talking shorelines being 50 50
miles different 400 feet different ocean
you know uh sea levels that's just you
know we don't get it if we do if we do
25 years as a generation uh 200 000
years is 8 000 Generations
okay so think about this now we now and
I like to put it this way the old models
of life and the evolution of Life were
very much just a steady state process
that at any given time it this is within
the darwinian models maybe 10 percent of
species are disappearing
at the same time 10 percent of new
species are appearing and in this model
one species generally simpler species
evolves into a higher more complex
species and
and at that point somewhere there's no
longer viable reproduction between those
those species anymore and that's what
you have a separate species right okay
yeah okay well here's the thing the in
the darwinian model the transitionary
phases should be way more than the two
endpoints of this Continuum but what has
been and this is the what the critics
have have
mounted this argument against the
darwinian evolution is where are all the
trans the the transitionary species
right well the skeletons or where is the
evidence of those yeah where is the
evidence of you know the transition from
you know one species to the next but
this was in the
pre-catastrophism days now it's pretty
much accepted that there has been a
succession of great catastrophes and The
Disappearance of species is probably
more attributable to catastrophic
wholesale
destruction of species that did not
leave progeny
and this is pretty well established now
you know I mean we've got the Permian
Triassic delayed or division the late
devonian the the the Jurassic Extinction
the KT the uh the uh eocene a legacy
we've got the extinction from 12 000
years ago where the you know the
mammoths and the giant ground sloths and
the saber-toothed cats they all
disappeared right so
species now appear to disappear
primarily during these wholesale
episodes of mass mortality right now the
other flip side is is the mysterious
side what is referred to as after a
Hiatus the rapid speciation all of a
sudden boom there's a proliferation of
new species where do they come right
right right and and you know just even
from a genetic standpoint some you know
the DNA splicing that can't be explained
and
um how you know we all of a sudden got
stood up where language came from like
these upgrades that came and that we
essentially I feel like I've heard that
we've kind of been about the same for
about 200 000 years yeah and within that
I mean there's a lot of stuff still
unexplained about our own history and I
guess one of the things I was kind of
getting to was we have this model now of
catastrophic destruction of species and
I think that the primary trigger foreign
is extraterrestrial the great impacts
that will cause rapid upheavals in the
in the stability of the planetary
biosystem the biosphere
and can also perhaps trigger geomagnetic
field events volcanism seismology the
onset and termination of glacial ages I
lean towards the idea that ultimately
the trigger is extraterrestrial and I
don't mean aliens I mean
extraterrestrial in the sense of comets
asteroids and their offspring this is
now becoming a much more accepted idea
by geologists and paleontologists and so
forth astronomers you know we're in this
position now where geologists have been
going along looking at the ground under
their feet and finding these hiatuses in
the geological record where it looks
like something really profound happened
and they're usually associated with
these mass extinction events at the same
time astronomers are looking at the
heavens they're finding out and
realizing that there's a whole lot more
stuff in our Cosmic neighborhood than
anybody was imagining a few Generations
ago I think these two things are coming
together and we're realizing that that
there is a cosmic a very important
Cosmic component to the rise and fall of
life on the planet but what I now think
is that by bringing it home I think we
can say that there's a cosmic influence
on the rise and fall of human
civilizations yeah and I think it's
possible
maybe even probable that there have been
civilizations
deep into pre-history that have been
completely lost now what archaeologists
the problem that archaeologists have and
this is what I've discovered by readings
particularly like the recent attacks on
Ancient apocalypse Graham Hancock show
is that archaeologists tend to focus on
one strata you know you might have an
archaeologist who for example devotes
decades to just looking at the evidence
of the Civil War right that is not going
to make them a expert on prehistory
right
but now what archaeologists and by
reading their
um their interpretations of of History
what is absent from their understanding
from their models of prehistory is
catastrophism
what they have not been cognizant of is
the
severe extent to which this planet has
been subject to these periodic resets
these periodic Global remodeling
episodes
when you take that into account and and
before we conclude I think we should
look at a few of those pictures I'll
pull them up just so you can kind of get
your head wrapped around the kinds of
events we're talking about here we're
talking about events that are on a
global scale that more or less erase
what was there
and it has to start over again
um
same with civilizations the other thing
the other thing that they're doing is
they're saying well we know that there
was no Advanced civilization because we
don't see any evidence of it well first
of all
again you're not taking into account the
severity of these Global changes and
secondly when you say Advanced
civilization what you're doing is you're
holding a mirror up
and you're imagining that if there was
an advanced civilization deep into
prehistoric past it must have looked
something like our own
I think that's flawed thinking I think
that there's possible Technologies out
there that a civilization could be built
on that don't look anything like
our fossil fuel based technologies that
we're using today yeah in fact we should
have another discussion about this
because right now uh some of the people
I've been working with for the last
several years this weekend will be
introducing
um a a demonstration at the Nikola Tesla
convention in Albuquerque I don't know
if you got wind of this but you know I
was on Joe Rogan's podcast uh a year ago
no that when was it a year ago November
I guess
and uh
well I've watched them yeah let's say I
was on there with Graham Hancock and
Graham's before we went on Graham said
let's not get into talking about
technology he wanted to talk about the
catastrophe well somewhere along the
line
Joe brought up the subject of of
Technology right and they kind of both
looked at me and and I had I think
Graham knew that I had been talking with
some people that had been building
prototypes in Spring there was a major
assembly of uh of some machinery
um in July the uh there was
um an implementation of this Machinery
on a 400 kilowatt generator that's part
of the London power grid and the
managers of the of the of the generating
plant were convinced enough of the
viability of this technology this is a
power source yes and it worked and and I
am putting together a complete
disclosure about all of it oh definitely
you just thought about that this weekend
at the Tesla convention in Albuquerque
New Mexico
the folks the colleagues I guess I could
call them are going to be there and
they're going to do a live stream
demonstration obviously anything in the
the space of energy free energy or
um using the ground like Tesla did and
Tesla's technology could have been
dangerous because it would have made
Wi-Fi essentially like a conductor and
and be dangerous for electronics but
there is overlaps between this and what
Tesla was doing but this has kind of
taken it in a different direction this
is energy system based on plasma there's
some stuff that I've been sitting on for
some time and would be a little
premature if we put it out there
publicly now six months or a year from
now yes I think we're going to blow the
gates off of the ancient history of good
there's some other people I've
interviewed too that have been working
hard on this in this space but funding
is hard and funding is hard yeah getting
people to believe them is hard and you
know getting patents is hard when you
get to go through the rigorous testing
of that's right outside of the testing
to have papers be pretty be be published
is it's a it's an uphill battle with
conventional science and those who are
trying to uphold that yeah that's the
goal is that between now and the end of
the year to get all of this stuff out
there where it can never be bottled up
again ever
because there have been others who have
have made inroads into this and like
like you said I mean there have been a
variety of different things that have
happened to suppression of their work
and so on but um I think this is the
this is the one where it's going to go
because it's already
reached the point where I don't think
they'll ever be able to
get this Genie back in the model it's
too late at this point what a time to be
alive you know I know I'm Gonna Be Alive
it is and so there's several things have
come together I think one is that from
what I've seen and learned
over the last few years I'm fairly well
convinced that what this represents is a
rediscovery of something that's been
lost
and in our conversation I'll show you
why I'll build the case
by taking looking at some of the some of
the stuff from the ancient Traditions
you look at these megalithic structures
you look at these you look at the the
location of them and you just think how
planetary alignments the the energy
produced the locations
um geolog geologically where they're
lined up I mean all these things like
how did they know this brings to the end
of the idea that I think that we've
really underestimated our own past
um we've created this scenario of kind
of you know the caveman
stereotype you know and and I think it's
blinded us to what has really gone on
and we've we've considered that that
this tremendously Rich Heritage of
Mythology and things that have come down
to us is just the the pre-scientific
illiterate oh they were they were so
ancient people who are so fearful that
they made up of the unknown that they
made up these stories and that has been
kind of the academic perspective on this
no these stories that have come down to
us are scientific ways of propagating
and perpetuating scientific information
of that I'm absolutely convinced and we
can unpack that and it's a gonna be a
it's a long conversation it's really
just getting underway but I think it's
going to contribute massively to
changing the direction of our own
history if we can get this information
out in time before we you know right now
there's this kind of dominant zero-sum
mentality that if we don't if we don't
fight for the diminishing resources
um you know we're going to lose out we
got to get these resources before the
Russians before the Chinese or whatever
it may be
but when in fact it's exactly the
opposite with just a flip of the switch
or a shift in our perspective we'll
realize that we suddenly have at our
fingertips these this tremendous almost
infinite resources and infinite energy
sources and it'll change the entire
Paradigm of modern history if if this if
this insight and this knowledge can can
get out in time and is not suppressed
and can you imagine what happens when
other Brilliant Minds can get involved
then and then we use we use our
intelligence to propel it look what
we've done in the last
50 years yeah see you make a very good
point there because if you think about
the Industrial Revolution you think
about the scientific Enlightenment let's
say go back to the days of Kepler and
Newton and in in Galileo and all those
guys right to now we're like three to
four hundred years now imagine look
where we've come from basically
feudalism
to the Space Age the age of that you're
sitting in where you are I'm sitting
where I am we're talking to each other
like I couldn't even imagine this I'm
old enough to remember when my dad
brought home our first ever television
set I remember the unboxing how exciting
it was to unbox a television right
um there was no had no presence in space
no computers when my grandparents were
born the primary mode of transportation
was horseback and foot
so I mean think about how far we've come
in just a few generations and that was
without connection now everything's
connected and it's accelerating the hell
out of everything it certainly is now
imagine this Danica
what we've done in the last three or
four centuries
imagine now you've got 200 000 years now
are we going to assume that all of those
time that all that vast span of time
humans with essentially the same size
brains as we've got now this presumably
the same intelligence didn't come up
with anything that we would now construe
as civilization and and how easily could
a thousand years or ten Thousand Years
be lost
and that's maybe should be our segue
into looking at some photos here for a
second before we run out of time
yes sir a large Boulder with a ant
walking on top of it yep okay that man
there that's Graham that's Graham cool
and what this is this is an erratic
Boulder it's basalt
and it was probably transported
somewhere between 50 and 100 miles from
its source
it's sitting on a ridge 400 feet above
the modern Columbia River
and how the hell did it get there oh my
God
and how do you know it was transported
versus there because we know where it
came from oh
it's an identifiable type of rock look
at this here's another very large
Boulder sitting on a hillside over here
you see there's another one and it's
about the same size if I had the rest of
the picture let's see that the top of
these Hills are
mantled with these gigantic Boulders
okay let's let's see if we can get it
there's a Basalt you said this is basalt
which is what is the energy is there a
certain conductivity of Basalt or what
is the well it can happen salt has a lot
of iron in it so I suppose it could be
conductive Basalt is is is formed from
lava
uh so you have a volcanic eruption and
in fact the or the ultimate origin of
this Basalt here that came out as lava
was a mantle plume that's now under
Yellowstone
National Park wow which began erupting
around 16 million years ago this was
actually transported around 12 or 13 000
years ago let's go to the next one so
type of rock called meta quartzite it's
a it's this is found this is was
originally one rock it comes from an
area near Jasper National Park in Canada
this is about 18 000 tons
it was one rock that's broken into three
pieces it's been transported somewhere
around 400 miles from its source and
mount mount Edith Cavell okay
now here's the interesting thing about
this this rock this erratic rock is
sitting on the uh Rocky Mountain front
in Alberta on the Prairie its origin in
Mount Edith cavel
is on the other side of the Continental
Divide
which raises a really interesting
question how do you
Quarry dislodge an 18
000 ton Rock transported over the
Continental Divide and drop it 400 miles
from its source out on the Prairie but
this was this was a geologist back in
the 1800s who was seeing some of these
erratic Boulders and surmised that the
only way you could explain them was
Iceberg transport icebergs you see right
here this Boulder sitting on an iceberg
in the iceberg being carried in these
this tremendous flow of water
well this amazingly is a very accurate
depiction of what actually happened
these so now this is Southern Idaho
right what this tells you Danica is that
this was water
on a mega scale
because you don't have any rivers on
Earth today transporting sediment like
this large swaths of planet Earth have
been dramatically shaped by Mega scale
flows of water yes no this isn't River
we're talking about this is like
you know glacial but there was no
glaciers here so this these were not
glacially transported they were they
were flood transported you can see in in
when you look at Boulders the rounding
of the boulders will tell you that these
were transported by water right are we
thinking this was when the the younger
driest warming occurred could be could
be
um there are a variety of dates on this
but they all place it within the same
window which is right at the end of the
last ice age and those mountains in the
background that you can see really look
like what happens when When the tide
When the tide goes back down and you see
these little quick ridges um that drain
off what you're looking at here is that
I'm standing at the bottom of a channel
400 feet deep and the water that came
through here cut the channel so prior to
this flood these Cliffs weren't here
right I would have been 400 feet under
the Bedrock right water came through
it cut this Channel and in cutting in a
channel it picked up
the the the Rock and and broke it up but
the rock that it was carrying this
Boulder bar that I'm standing on is
hundreds of feet thick and three miles
long
so there's 100 there's millions of these
Boulders that are of this tremendous
size and again
since this happened
there has been no for this is actually
near the Snake River Southern Idaho
nothing in the Snake River has even come
remotely close
to this current flow here so this
deposit is like a fossil it was created
in a single event
and it's been sitting there for 12 to 14
000 years somewhere in that range
with little to no modification at all
but what you're seeing here is this is
Horseshoe Falls the Canadian falls
juxtaposed upon a cataract from an
ancient waterfall and they're at the
same scale wow and you're seeing the
remnants of horseshoe cataract here
that's two and a half times the height
of Niagara and five times I'm sorry 10
times as wide it's five miles wide the
next one is an aerial photograph that
will show you
by scale this is a cataract it's called
wow so that would have been a waterfall
that you got it this was a waterfall a
gigantic waterfall that created that
that created this and again this is a
fossil feature here and you can see it
the erosion of this goes way over to the
yeah limit the water here that created
this is Flowing towards us right and so
this was an aerial photograph I took God
25 years ago maybe now but when I was
really first studying this stuff in
Earnest and so I've put Horseshoe Falls
up here in the corner at the same scale
so that you can see that that Niagara
Falls would be utterly dwarfed by this
ancient Falls this was not even the
biggest one but this the the the peak
discharge that created this was about
350 million cubic feet per second
how do you put that into perspective
every take every river from every
continent on Earth think of every Big
River you can every medium Every Little
River all of them the Amazon the Nile
the Columbia the Mississippi the
Missouri the poe the Yellow River in
China The Orinoco the Congo all of them
together
wouldn't be one-tenth of the flow that
created this holy
so now ask yourself
um
an event like this what's it going to
leave in its aftermath
this is
400 feet of bedrock that was
catastrophically just ripped out
by the waterfall the water flow through
here and you can actually tell because
if you go off this channel you can find
the high water mark the water here was
400 feet deep so the water was as deep
as this Cliff is high and at the peak of
the flood
all you would have seen is a bump and in
this water
raging turbulent water would have been
thousands of icebergs
because this is the catastrophic melting
of the great ice sheets over Canada to
the north that's what we're seeing here
these are potholes that are drilled into
Bedrock now this is right in my backyard
this is North Carolina
but what this shows you is that first of
all you ask a question how what forces
turbulent flows of water can drill holes
in Bedrock
like this and look here up here you see
the yeah the modern Creek had nothing to
do with the creation of this pothole
this pothole was created by rapidly very
deep rapidly moving water
um that was so turbulent that once you
have turbulence you have this property
of water when it gets turbulent enough
it almost wants to self-organize just
like the weather does when it when you
have two like a cold front and a warm
front clashing and you get tornadoes
the same phenomenal and what you have to
actually picture here is that you've got
very deep swiftly moving water and
you're literally looking like at an
underwater tornado now I'm here I'm
looking into a pothole here that's 70
feet deep can you imagine the flow of
water now again this is up along the
Saint Croix wild and Scenic river that
forms the border between Wisconsin and
Northern Minnesota
this was produced by catastrophic
melting of the ice sheets to the north
um I got another picture here
taken from in the bottom of another
pothole
that's our good friend Graham Hancock
there I
spent a couple of weeks with him guiding
him through some of these uh areas of
catastrophe so he could see firsthand
while he was writing magicians of the
Gods
this the the last thing we did at the
end of our journey from Portland to the
Twin Cities uh was we visited these
giant potholes
so that he could get a sea for himself
the power of these floods that could
drill in some cases some of these giant
potholes are 20 feet wide and 80 feet
deep now this was I took this in the
aftermath of Hurricane Ivan which came
through Georgia when was a 2009 I
believe
and what happens this is called excuse
me if you look at the the caption
imbrication now imagine that you have a
bookshelf
Danica and you push you you have a stack
of books and you push from One Direction
and all of the books lean over yeah
well water will move rocks and then it
will deposit those rocks in a very
similar manner you can see up here I've
got the current flow the direction the
rocks will be tilted in the direction of
the current flow yeah that makes sense
yeah makes sense doesn't it yeah
um here's another example and once
you've seen it it's very clear and I'm
doing a little walkie-talkie in there
for for scale right and you can see the
embricate Rocks Yep this was this was a
hundred year flood
Hurricane Ivan it came through here
because this is like 20 feet 25 feet
above the modern Creek look at the size
of these this is imbrication
current flow is is like it's you see the
arrow here from right to left right
which shouldn't kind of give you a
multiple and scale you could probably do
some math on that of the oh yeah weight
of that Rock versus
those Boulders are monsters
and you've got to begin to think about
what kind of water flow
would move Boulders and stack Boulders
like that well so what I've been doing
and the thing is it's not just an ocean
or like it's flow
yeah it's flowing it's moving it like
it's just like this is Raging it's
raging and it's probably hundreds of
feet deep and and nothing
subsequent to the event that put these
rocks here has had anywhere even
remotely close to the ability to alter
the effects of that one event one of the
great
um uh paleo hydrologists of our modern
time Victor Baker who's done a lot of
work has in a paper that he's got that I
like to quote he's his he realized and
he it's an actual quote from one of his
peer-reviewed scientific papers that one
of the primary geomorphic
um shaping events on the planet on Earth
has been plant this is his term
planetary scale movement of water
absolutely so when you're talking about
planetary scale movement of water I can
tell you this Danica if these kinds of
events the younger driest type of ants
in these flooding type events were to
happen today
ten thousand years from now
archaeologists would be having a hard
time finding evidence that we were here
right now this you can look here modern
Snake River average annual discharge
let's just call it 57 000 cubic feet per
second that's this River down here which
is a pretty vigorous River if you go
rafting or canoeing on this it's a
pretty vigorous River
the Bonneville flood was up to 40 40
million cubic feet per second and that's
what created this channel so the entire
Snake River the largest Hundred Year
floods might come up and submerge the
flood plain but there has been no flood
since this Bonneville flood that has
ever been able to rise up over the rim
and flood the surrounding areas the
modern Snake River even in its largest
flood capacity is completely trapped
within this ancient Channel and let me
tell you that virtually every river in
North America
is flowing in an ancient Channel that's
completely oversized relative to the
modern River that's flowing in it once
you begin to understand the magnitude of
this planetary scale remodeling now you
can really go okay maybe there was a lot
more going on in prehistoric times than
we have been willing to admit well the
man the most dangerous thing to the
powers to be that you know make all the
money and control the elements the
Commodities of the world is that we all
understand that there are far better
ways far more efficient ways far more
technology that's available that we
don't have to live in this fashion we
can evolve I would think the core of why
people would suppress it is because it
there are people making money off of the
archaic ways that we're going about
using Commodities and oil and different
things to you know continue our life uh
that they don't want to lose
some people will lose money and some
people will make money the people that
have it don't want to let go of it yeah
and that's always the way it is with
progress so I'm curious as a as a last
question of what your goal is with all
of this work well my goal is to get this
information out because I think that for
one thing I don't think we can have a
realistic
strategy for our future on this planet
without understanding the past that's
one thing and I mentioned earlier this
the kind of the zero-sum mindset that
you know which is basically you know the
malthusian view that resources are
finite and if one side gets access to
resources the other side won't and I
think that's a completely obsolete view
of the world and I believe that our
Technologies uh waiting in the wings
that completely will change the whole
Paradigm of how we consume energy on
this planet also the realization that
look we are vulnerable
and we need to work together
internationally see this was to me like
a wake-up call tunguska was a wake-up
call of 1908. it showed us what can
happen and there is evidence in hand now
and this can be another discussion we
have but the evidence like what happened
at the younger driest
was probably not a big single impact
like what knocked out the dinosaurs was
probably a multiple impact event that
involved hundreds if not thousands of
tunguska-like objects right almost like
having a nuclear war without the
radiation but if you imagine unleashing
6 000 nuclear weapons
on half the planetary surface
I think that's kind of what we're
looking at as far as the younger driest
that influences the elements instead of
sort of some sort of toxic nuclear
fallout it's the elements we're talking
about water ice fire fire
ice there's an Old English saying water
and fire have no mercy fire and water
have no mercy and there's a lot of
interesting old traditions about that
you know I mean the the Mayans believed
destruction of the World by fire
alternating with destruction of the
World by water the Greeks had the same
tradition about alternate catastrophes
the Hopi Indians
um and I've had the privilege lately of
of being able to sit directly and learn
some of the the Traditions from the
storytellers both of the Zuni and the
Hopi and interestingly what's going on
and and I'll make this very quick is
that a lot of the with with the modern
era a lot of the young people growing up
in the tribes have lost interest in the
ancient stories and they're more
interested in the the internet and the
you know whatever all the stuff
distractions the distractions of the
world exactly and so now some of these
tribes that have held these Traditions
very close are becoming much more
liberal about
sharing their Traditions yeah somebody's
got a somebody has to carry the stories
that's right that's right and I've had
the opportunity of being out in the
deserts with some of these not far from
where you are yeah it's not it's the
Hopi the Hopi Hopi area is not very far
it's just further a little bit north and
being you know fairly well inversed in
the science of paleo hydrology which is
the science of these ancient great flood
flows the consistency between my
understanding from science and what's
being related in these stories to me is
remarkable
which just tells me yes these are real
authentic traditions and we can learn a
lot from them so that's another kind of
dimension of this whole thing you're
here to usher in the next era you know
to to be a truth seller too I hope so
yeah yeah it always takes brave people
smart motivated and curious people and
um to to to bring in something new and
you know I'm sure there's been a few
points in time where maybe people have
thought you've been off your rails but
it's happened some of the most brilliant
were the the most brilliant people in
history what one of them has been
someone that's considered super rational
and has their together and
everything they're saying is completely
you know uh a believable like no one no
one no one that no one that brings in
great new knowledge is really has a has
has gone through time being excluded
from that club of being a little crazy
so let's bring it on good I like that
let's bring it on I think I think we're
due for some really exciting things in
the next few years I love it I love it
well thank you so much thanks everybody
for listening to the pretty intense
podcast today I hope you enjoyed it if
you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
Subscribe button